[Musique]
on fait un ou deux reportages sur la
situation des femmes en égypte pourquoi
on se concentre là dessus c'est que en
2010 un an avant les révoltes du
printemps arabe
j'étais venu en egypte pour faire un
reportage sur la situation des femmes
vues à travers leur évolution dans le
football
en egypte le sport évidemment nationale
le football féminin salaire d'un sujet
banal mais ce ne l'est pas du tout dans
un pays musulman donc on s'est dit qu'on
reviendrait voir si effectivement ses
droits avaient progressé stagner ou
reculer depuis 2011
alors il y a eu quelques petites
victoires nous disent des féministes à
qui on a pu parler
par contre est-ce que les femmes sont
plus libres aujourd'hui qu'en 2011 ou
avant 2011 ça c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à dire parce que la liberté
d'expression qu'on avait vu exploser sur
la place tahrir en 2011 n'est plus
aujourd'hui au contraire il est très
difficile de parler aux gens il est même
on a même vu une banderole à l'entrée
d'une porte d'une banque où il était
indiqué en gros et en rouge
il est interdit de parler de politique
ça dit beaucoup
le plus difficile en egypte c'est
vraiment de raconter une oppression sans
avoir aucune image pour l'illustrer il
est absolument impossible de tourner
quelques bâtiments publics que ce soit
et c'est pas juste qu'on n'a pas le
droit de les tourner c'est que quand il
ya des policiers de partout
s'il nous voient souvent ils vont nous
accosté nous interpeller nous demander
nos autorisations de tournage
l'autre difficulté c'est de parler à des
dissidents à des victimes de cette
oppression
ils sont soit en prison soit terrorisé
par là par l'idée d'être arrêtés et
emprisonnés et en présentant pour
obtenir nos autorisations ce sujet sur
la situation des femmes
on a peur on n'a pas menti on a on fait
ce qu'on a dit qu'on ferait monde disons
qu'on n'a pas tout dit et c'est la même
chose à chaque fois qu'on est arrêté on
ne dit pas tout parce que on n'aurait
pas pu venir dans l'egypte et on
n'aurait pas pu faire ce reportage si on
avait tout dit ce qu'on avait le désir
de faire
[Musique]
la plus grande surprise ça a été de voir
la place tahrir
là où j'ai vu il y a dix ans le peuple
s'approprier sa liberté d'expression
réaliser le pouvoir de la rue
c'était vraiment émouvant de voir les
égyptiens venir vers nous assoiffés de
me dire enfin leur souffrance leur
quotidien leurs espoirs aussi et
aujourd'hui ben j'ai découvert que cette
place tahrir s'est transformée en
forteresse c'est une prison surveillés
par des centaines de militaires à peu
près au 10 mai m donc évidemment les
policiers et les militaires qui sont là
ont la mission d'empêcher tout début de
rassemblement et franchement à entendre
les gens nous parlent et ceux qui osent
nous parlait il n'y a pas d'espoir pour
qu'il y ait un nouveau mouvement pour
tenter de faire tomber ce régime
[Musique]
ma rencontre la plus touchante c'est
vraiment avec mona à thala et sa belle
famille allard mona c'est la première
femme qui est devenu arbitre en egypte
arbitres dans les ligues d'hommes alors
il y avait déjà quelques femmes arbitres
qui arbitrait des matchs de femmes met
donc une femme qu'on avait rencontré il
y a dix ans elle était tout gêné toute
timide et ça a été magnifique comme
retrouva il se souvenait nous et surtout
c'est que j'ai retrouvé une mona affirmé
beaucoup plus sûre d'elle très souriante
une femme forte donc une des belles
retrouvailles émouvantes et d'ailleurs
on a été accueillis comme des rois même
si on est arrivés complètement
l'improviste un bon moment de ce
tournage c'est que après qu'ils aient
accepté généreusement de nous accorder
une entrevue qu'on puisse faire le
tournage avec eux ils nous ont offert un
repas typiquement égyptien c'était
vraiment délicieux et ben il soit là
c'était notre premier tournage en egypte
mais ça reste mon plus touchant
[Musique]
l'egypte est un pays très important
stratégiquement à la fois pour
l'équilibré des puissances dans la
région et aussi pour les etats-unis
c'est le principal allié dans la région
des américains de l'occident dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est pour ça qu'on avait toléré si
longtemps les abus de pouvoir et les
violations des droits humains sous hosni
moubarak
et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on tolère en
ce moment les mêmes abus de pouvoir et
les mêmes violations des droits l'egypte
est le principal pays arabes qui est en
paix avec israël
c'est aussi encore le principal allié de
la palestine on a tendance à l'oublier à
se concentrer sur le conflit entre les
palestiniens et israël
mais c'est l'egypte qui fait en sorte
que ce conflit n'a pas éclaté en conflit
régional qui aurait pu vraiment avoir
des conséquences terribles
donc c'est un pays important c'est une
population attachante éduqués qui est
étouffée en ce moment je pense qu'il est
important de venir les écouter et vous
dire comment il se sent dix ans plus
tard
[Musique]